job the chase with the go sharks where  they're pursuing the the rowboat  we shot part of that in a location where  we were adding the island to the  background then we had a small water  tank location with a rowboat on a gimbal  for a direct interaction with people in  water whoa we then did another  environment where we shot in a  blue-screen stage and an interior so  within that sequence you might be  cutting from a location to a tank shot  to a blue screen set all in a matter of  a few seconds and our job was to try to  make sure that we were creating the cg  water and the VCG ocean extensions  around it to match the live-action  location well enough that it blends we  kind of have the best of both worlds we  have the digital portion at hand and we  have the practical stuff that was shot  and set in each of these shots in small  ways a combination it depends on what  works best  [Music]